es momento de hablar de economía en
france 24 por ello me acompaña en el
estudio mi compañero jorge hurtado jorge
bienvenido iniciamos con los datos de
las principales bolsas a la baja así es
la venta de activos de riesgo aumento
por la preocupación del estancamiento de
la deuda en eeuu todo después de una
reunión en el senado donde el presidente
de la reserva federal quiere powell y la
secretaria del tesoro o janet yellen
advirtieron que un impago de eeuu por no
elevar el techo de la deuda tendría
graves consecuencias para la economía en
ese país las declaraciones se dan luego
de que los republicanos bloquearan por
segunda vez un proyecto demócrata para
elevar el límite de esta deuda cabe
destacar valentine que la deuda de eeuu
es la referencia mundial de
endeudamiento esto dijo la secretaria
del tesoro
es imperativo que el congreso aborde el
techo de deuda si no nuestra estimación
actual es que el tesoro probablemente
agotará sus medidas extraordinarias para
el 18 de octubre en ese momento el
tesoro se quedaría con recursos muy
limitados que se agotarán rápidamente
eeuu dejaría de pagar por primera vez en
la historia la fe y el crédito de los
eeuu se verían afectados y nuestro país
probablemente enfrentaría una crisis
financiera y una recesión económica como
resultado sus en y que no weezer
newsweek scholtz valentina pero la pelea
política entre republicanos y demócratas
no es lo único que hizo caer las bolsas
la economía mundial enfrenta a una
acumulación de fuerzas estanflación
arias por el aumento de los precios de
la energía en europa y china que impulsa
la inflación y frena la recuperación de
la recesión por la pandemia los
economistas lo llaman estanflación este
término se acuñó por primera vez en los
años 60 cuando el ministro de finanzas
del reino unido junto a las palabras
estancamiento más inflación para
describir lo que estaba pasando
en su economía y se vuelve a usar en
estos momentos vamos ahora con los
indicadores de la jornada bueno wall
street cerró con pérdidas tras los
comentarios del presidente de la reserva
federal sobre la inflación sólo el
índice nasdaq que aglutina las
tecnológicas más importantes del mundo
vivió su peor día al perder un 2.83 por
ciento en europa la bolsa descendieron
afectadas por la baja de las plazas
internacionales y el retroceso del
petróleo según datos del mercado y en
américa latina la principal baja se dio
en brasil afectada por el escenario
exterior con china y eeuu como
principales factores de inestabilidad
cambiamos de tema porque hay noticias de
las pensiones en chile así en la cámara
de diputados de chile aprobó el martes
un cuarto retiro del 10 por ciento de
los fondos de pensiones que de ser
respaldados por el senado dará la
posibilidad a que unos 10 millones de
chilenos puedan retirar unos 17 mil
millones de dólares
la propuesta fue aprobada con 94 votos a
favor 39 en contra y 9 abstenciones
ahora será el senado el que va a decidir
si los chilenos podrán retirar por
cuarta ocasión parte de los fondos
destinados a sus futuras jubilaciones en
los primeros tres retiros los chilenos
sacaron unos 50.000 millones de dólares
y con un cuarto podrían agregarse otros
17 mil millones y en méxico las
autoridades brindaron datos sobre el
empleo así es un informe del instituto
nacional de estadística y geografía
aseguró que el empleo se recuperó en
agosto pero la precariedad continúa en
ese país el desempleo en méxico se situó
en un 4,3 por ciento de la población
económicamente activa en el mes pasado
una cifra inferior al 5,3 por ciento del
mismo período en 2020 cuando las
economías estaban al borde debido a la
pandemia aunque los números del empleo
pueden percibirse como positivos la
ocupación informal en agosto de 2021
creció a 31.4 millones y se situó en el
56,4 por ciento esto significa a
valentina que más de la mitad de las
personas ocupadas en mexico laboran en
la informalidad
precariedad
datos preocupantes jorge cerramos con la
cifra del día así es la cifra es 12.3
millones de dólares para el gobierno
español en subvenciones para
damnificados del volcán en la isla de la
palma el dinero será destinado para
alojamientos y ayudas ahí la lava
destruyó 589 edificios y 21 kilómetros
de carreteras bueno y todavía no se ve
que vaya a finalizar los daños de esta
catástrofe pueden faltar días y subir un
montón esta cifra jorge muchas gracias
por la información y a ustedes por su
sintonía continúen con nosotros que hay
más noticias aquí en france 24
[Música]
i